- So the US midterm
elections are coming up fast
and the results can have a huge impact
on the final two years of
President Donald Trump's
current term in office
and if you're wondering what
the hell midterm elections are?
Don't worry!
'Cause I'm about to let
you know in 60 seconds,
right after I eat this Carolina Reaper.
(crunching pepper)
Oh, my god.
Basically midterm elections take place,
as the name implies, at the halfway point
between presidential elections
and federal election during
which members of Congress
are selected by voters.
This includes all 435 members
of the US House of Representatives
and one third of US Senators.
This year if Democrats
were to win the house
they'd be able to (gasping)
They would be able to, oh god!
(banging on wall)
- [Cameraman] 20 seconds.
Finish it off.
- This year, oh I can't do it.
(record scratching to a halt)
I'm gonna do the full
monologue one time clean.
I need to make sure I get these takes
because afterwards I won't
be able to do a clean take.
Basically midterm elections take place,
as the name implies, at the halfway point
between presidential elections
and our federal elections
during which members of Congress
are selected by voters.
This includes all 435 members
of the US House of Representatives
and one third of US Senators.
You might be wondering,
what's so important?
Because maybe this is
quite as jazzy sounding
as presidential elections but no,
these elections are incredibly important
because the results will dictate
whether the Democratic or Republican party
will control each chamber of Congress
and whichever party controls each chamber
will have an easier time
passing proposed legislation
in their chamber.
This year, if Democrats
were to win the house
they would be able to decide
which bills come to the floor,
control committee chairmanships,
add support over a certain investigation
of Trump's administration.
If Republicans maintain the Senate,
they'll be able to appoint
conservative judges
and approve Trump's cabinet nominees.
So regardless of where
you lean politically,
get out there and exercise
your right to vote.
This is the time to make your voice heard.
Jack, it's burning.
- Yeah I bet.
- Jack!
- What?
(phone going off)
- It hurts!
This is where I die.
(laughing)
- [Jack] Aw, look at that, he's in pain,
he's still making jokes. (laughing)